welcome everyone so essentially I
received court will end up with the
session on the my method and also the
last session of the Wood Cup of this
talk to long term proxy fans remember
that there is an All Hands meeting in 3
p.m. in the same room so please come
here because we need to discuss
important stuff about what will we do
after such a great week thank you very
much for the introduction for having me
and thank you very much the organizers
for putting together such a wonderful
program for the week and thank you to
all of you for sticking it around to the
bitter end of boot camp and coming back
even after a lunch on this lovely day so
today I'll be giving the last talk in
this series of talks have been giving on
interior point methods and the last few
talks I think have gone really well into
the details of interior point methods I
think you've all seen a few very nice
presentations of the proofs of how
interior point methods work and how they
can be analyzed given that it's the end
that it's the end of boot camp and after
lunch at the end of the week I thought
I'd end things by giving a little more
high-level view of some of the recent
developments of Interior and point
methods and give a little bit more of a
geometric explanation of some of the
things you've already seen earlier in
the week so the focus on this talk will
be giving another sort of high-level
geometric perspective on interior point
methods going over what the actual
end-to-end algorithmic complexity is of
using of interior point methods in a
variety of contexts and hope you'll get
a sense of some of what some of the
leading leading cutting-edge research
happening in interior point methods is
and how you can use them down the road
and since I guess also because it's the
end of the bootcamp I might go off on a
little bit of a rant of what I think
some of the big open problem directions
are in interior point methods so plan
for the talk is as follows first to warm
us all up after lunch I'll recap what
we've seen though just about basic
linear programming interior point
methods I'll use this to springboard us
into discussing what the actual best
intent runtimes we have right now are
for linear programming it'll make some
combinatorial connections there and then
I'll spend the bulk of the talk talking
about some of the fastest augur
we have four linear programming these
interior point if methods and go a
little bit more under how to leverage
geometric perspectives on interior point
methods to build these recent fastest
algorithms for solving them and at the
end is we have time I might go off and
talk about I think a little bit more in
detail some of what I think the big open
problems are interior point methods and
or more break down I think the obvious
open problems interior point methods
into I think some arcs that if you
myself and a bunch of other researchers
have been exploring so that's the plan
the main bulk of the talk when I go into
this analysis of this geometric
perspective and I go and start talking
about how to leverage it to get faster
algorithms I'll be primarily there
talking about joint work with Yin Tetley
who's I think finishing up his last week
as a postdoc in Microsoft Research and
starting as a professor uw next week I
think all right so that's the plan for
the talk so let's take it back to where
we were at the end of the last sessions
on interior point methods like the
previous talks our main focus will be on
solving linear programming using
interior point methods so a central
object for the rest of the talk we have
an arbitrary linear program where we
have some n variables X we have some set
of D variables X we have some cost
vector C our goal is to minimize the
inner product of X and C we want to do
it subject to end linear inequality
constraints given by some constraint
matrix a and some constraint vector B
now what I've written here is just a
dual of a linear program in standard
form it's similar no I'll be using
similar notation to Maju but I think I
changed the dimensions a little bit so
another little tweak on the setting but
we've seen this before so this is a
general linear program and this will be
our main object of study but I'll note a
lot of the analysis I'll be doing does
extend to general convex programming so
if you want to be thinking of a bonus
problem I guess as I go through the rest
of the talk you can think about where am
I really using anywhere about it being a
linear programming throughout the rest
of the analysis all right so just quick
refresh what do these things look like
we have these end inequality constraints
every inequality constraint I find some
half space in RN the intersection of
these and half spaces is our feasible
region given by x equals B it's going to
be this high demand
a convex body I'll call polytope
whenever I draw the feasible region for
the rest the talk I'll just draw its
contour and blue and whenever I draw
them will always have the cost vector
that we're doing pointed straight up so
for the rest of the talk our goal is to
find the bottom of this high dimensional
convex body and that's our goal
all right we've all seen some discussion
the standard methods for solving them
there's the simplex method where you
walk along the boundary the ball ito up
towards the bottom there's a lip SOI
door cutting plane methods which we saw
a little bit more about earlier today
where you start with some large convex
set that contains the entire feasible
region we iteratively shrink it till it
contains nothing but oft there's
interior point methods which is what
I'll focus on which as we've seen walk
around in the interior of the polytope
now I think there's a number of reasons
to study of interior point method is a
number of which have already been
discussed a little bit earlier in
general I think they're worth study
because they're just a very pervasive
robust convex optimization framework if
you want to solve optimization problems
that are possibly very old conditioned
something like gradient descent won't
necessarily converge fast and if you
want a very high precision answer so you
want very good dependence on the
accuracy you're in and so for like poly
logarithmic dependence on your error
threshold and these are often a tool of
choice at least in theory and in many
cases the fastest algorithms we have in
practice in a variety of contexts and
unlike maybe cutting plane methods in a
variety of contexts as Steven I think
very well articulated earlier in the
week often the interior point methods
can do much much better than the best
theory for them we actually we can
actually predict by their theory beyond
this as theorists I think they're worth
studying because I think one of the main
points I'll try to emphasize when I go
through some of the geometric views of
interior point methods is I think they
actually provide a very nice lens and a
rich theory for sort of thinking about
the geometry and thinking about the
structure of convex sets more broadly so
by thinking about the progress interior
point methods make and how fast or how
slowly they run and what they are
actually doing in every single iteration
I think underneath this it's a good lens
for finding a lot of structure and
optimization problems you want to solve
and also for as I'll talk about a bit
for a variety of optimization problems
the fastest algorithms we have for when
the optimization problem is a sufficient
amount of structure in many cases in the
number of cases is only growing the
fastest algorithms we have in some way
shape or form using to your point
methods and there's many open problems
right so it's refreshed we've seen to
the I can't get to your phone methods
are two key ideas behind them the first
key idea is to stay in the interior
right they all work by starting in the
interior the polytope maintaining a
feasible point and walking towards the
bottom and the other key idea is to
really stay in the interior so as we've
seen in both yeah
point of clarification on this this came
up at Steve's talk yesterday it's like
what into what interior right because
what's weird like especially with these
new outlets it's just about trying to
make sure that the the accident so what
does that be a cure of it we're doing it
very feasible method so there I guess
ideas you're turning there you're
turning and feasibility into a soft
constraint so the idea is you want to
have a nice way of quantifying and
feasibility or quantifying whatever you
so I think there you're defining a way
that you're trivially and you're
trivially feasible but now going towards
certain sets of the constraints lets you
quantify how infeasible you are so it
gives you a nice way of what I was going
to say the next one is sort of
quantifying things like distance from
the boundary from cost functions which
in the context when you run these things
originally in something interiors
quantifying the trade-off between
infeasibility the distance from
feasibility and the cost function you're
trying to optimize but a really good
question
yes sir cool alright so sang the other
idea is to stay in the interior so the
other idea behind all the interior point
methods we've discussed I think rather
than the other implicitly as we saw with
the primal-dual methods or very
explicitly as we had in the path
following methods is some idea of
quantifying our distance from the
constraint set in the primal-dual
methods we were explicitly maintaining
bounds on complimentary slackness which
was how far we stayed away from the
constraints and the path following
methods we explicitly kept around this
barrier function that penalized how far
we stayed away from the boundary so the
key idea and all of this is that we want
a very formal way to sort of trade off
caring about cost functions and distance
from constraints all right now before I
give what the actual best end-to-end
running times are of interior point
methods and I talked about their
complexity when used to solve linear
programming I should give a quick
disclaimer as we've seen interior point
methods don't refer to any one specific
method and like all the methods I think
many of the methods we've seen this week
for solving optimization problems they
instead refer to a fairly broad
framework for turning difficult convex
optimization problems into sequences of
much simpler optimization problems so I
think if you want to talk about a
variety of different interior point
methods and you want to talk about their
running time while for something like
linear programming you can ultimately
say what the end run time is for a
linear programming I think to understand
what's going on it's often very helpful
to break down the analysis of these
methods into two pieces one how many
subproblems do you solve when you're
trying to solve this difficult
optimization problem and using this
framework to break it down to a number
of simple problems how many problems you
need to solve and now harder those
subproblems alright so in the case of
the interior point methods we've seen
for linear programming the number of
we've talked a lot about the number of
iterations that's how many problems were
gonna solve and there the iteration
complexity was always doing some sort of
Newton's method and so the Newton steps
the question is what's the complexity of
forming that linear system and solving
it I am talking about the running times
for interior point methods
not going to distinguish too much
between some of the different
perspectives we've seen a primal dual or
predictor-corrector or potential
reduction or path following for more of
the classic results in terms of runtime
there
each of these met in terms of
theoretical analysis they all get
essentially the same bounce although
there's a bunch of interesting work to
go between them and there's a variety of
advantages and disadvantages so I mainly
focus on this and a little less on the
actual structure okay all right so with
that in mind what's the actual running
time needed what's the actual running
time of interior point methods for
linear programming so here I'm writing
the sort of the history of theoretical
improvements to interior point methods
for linear programming here I'm just
running the number of iterations as the
number of iterations need to get one
more bit of precision so I'm just
dropping things like log of initial
error over final error or how many bits
of precision you need to actually round
to a feasible solution if you do
infeasible start so just giving the
rough number the number of iterations
they need and the complexity of each
iteration all right so the first proof
of an interior point method running in
polynomial time is due to Karmakar and
there the number of iterations the
interior point needed was proportional
to the number of constraints of the
linear program and and the complexity of
every iteration of that method was
comparable to that of solving a single
linear system or in particular solving a
single linear system no it wasn't an
arbitrary linear system that you have to
solve as we it's the of the type we saw
when Stephen did his analysis earlier in
the week essentially the running time of
every iteration of Congress method was
dominated by the cost of projecting a
single vector onto the image of a under
some rescaling of all the rows so the
linear system you have to solve is
essentially a regression problem that
looks like this
where D is just some diagonal matrix
that you should think of rescaling every
single row of a or another way say the
cost of every iteration was that of
solving a certain linear system in a
transpose a under again this rescaling
this was improved by Rettig r in 1986
who showed that
you can get a method where's my rent a
garden 1986 showed you only need square
it you can improve this to square root
and number of iterations where the
complexity of every iteration was
essentially the same and across a broad
range of parameters the fastest ovens we
have in theory and so recently were
primarily a variant of Rena gars
algorithm tailored to the specific
instance however in general further
solving a linear program the number of
constraints can be much much larger than
the number of variables and the
convergence rate then of this method can
slow down however fortunately there were
these two very cool results of via in
1989 who showed you can get algorithms
that depend just a little bit better on
the dimension of the polytope
d rather than the number of constraints
it takes to write it down and and you
could get this improvement with an
interior point method that takes just a
little bit more it's a bit more time per
iteration instead of having the cost of
every iteration being that of solving a
certain regression problem or certain
linear system should think the
complexity of every iteration of these
methods was dominated by the cost of
either writing down the entire
projection matrix which you can do more
or less by solving roughly and linear
and linear systems or the complexity of
computing at least the diagonal of this
matrix so you can get a better rate but
you have to do a bit more a bit more
work for every iteration this was
further improved by a very beautiful
result of Nesterov in nemirovsky in 1994
who showed that you can improve these
methods to have a number of it or a
given interior point method with a
number of iterations you need just
depending on square root of the
dimension so you can importantly improve
from square root of the number of
constraints the square root of dimension
but unfortunately the cost of every
iteration of this algorithm involves
solving a subproblem that was more
expensive than linear programming itself
all right so the first time you hear
this this might sound a little silly if
I give you Oracle access to something
that's strictly harder than solving when
you're programming I should be able to
solve a linear program in one iteration
just by solving the linear program but
what was really interesting about this
result is in a strong sense this is not
what they did
instead what they did is they showed
there exists a single barrier that
depends only on the geometry of the
polytope not the cost function they are
trying to optimize called the universal
barrier and they showed that if you
build an interior point method using
this barrier function then this interior
point method converges at a square root
dimension rate so in some times you
could think what they were arguing was
then if you understood the geometry of a
polytope well enough that you could
construct this more sophisticated
barrier then in theory you should be
able to get it into your point method
that converges at the right rate just
didn't address sort of the complexity of
sort of getting that structural
understanding of the particular polytope
you're trying to optimize over and for
the last four until fairly recently this
looked like the state-of-the-art for
interior point methods for linear
programming it looked like you can get
methods that depend better and better on
the trinsic dimension of the polytope t
rather the number of constraints and if
you were willing to spend more and more
time per iteration and it looked like
there was a natural trade-off you get
there so the main results I'm going to
tell you about or build up to by the end
of this talk is work again to be and I
did in the last few years that showed
you need not have such a bad trade-off
you can get an algorithm that up to poly
logarithmic factors has the same
convergence rate of the universal
barrier while having iteration costs
that are comparable to that of
rent-a-cars algorithm just solving
computing projections onto the image of
rescaling sub a so if you want to use
this result to get algorithms for linear
programming you just need to look at the
complexity of solving every single
linear system solving a linear system
and if use recent work on stochastic
methods or subspace embeddings for
solving linear systems the best running
time we have for implementing every one
of these iterations by itself is time
that's linear and the size of the
constraint matrix basically linear in
the size of the input plus the time
needed to solve D by D linear system so
D D Omega or Omega is the matrix
multiplication constant so that's what
you get from directly using this result
however it's been no
even since the first work of karmic are
showing that interior point methods that
can be solved in polynomial time that
you can often get wins on improving the
overall running time to execute it into
your point method by leveraging how much
the linear systems you're solving at
every iteration of an interior point
method change so it turns out when you
run all of these methods in some sense
the fact that they take a number of
methods to converge you can actually tie
back to bounds on how much the hessian
or how much the linear system you have
to solve in every iteration of these
interior point methods change you can
show on average they don't change by too
much and even since the earlier the
first work of Karmakar there's been a
sequence of results showing you can that
you exploit this to make the cost of
solving each linear system sort of
cheaper and cheaper in average yeah so
you only need to solve them so you only
let's see the linear is whatever no you
only need to solve what's the best way
to say this so you don't you don't need
to solve them exactly you can quantify
the number of bits of precision you need
and you need in the answer so that's
exactly where this run time exactly
that's where that running time comes
from right you only need to solve them
up to like log the accuracy ran before
it bits of precision you can quantify it
and from preconditioning that means you
actually only need to able to solve a
linear system of approximately related
matrix you don't have to actually solve
for it and matrix so there's a bunch of
sequence of work show you can get better
and better running times we showed you
can adapt those that work to this to
this result that has a slightly faster
rate so things change a little bit more
and combine it with all the sampling
tricks so you can make it so that on
average the cost of solving the linear
systems are as if the matrix
multiplication constant was two so the
run time you get for linear programming
is the size of the linear program x
squared of dimension plus dimension to
the 2.5
okay so what I want to do in the rest of
the talk is tell you a bit about the
geometric insights that underlie this
result and how to think of going from
something like Rena gars algorithm to
this slightly better convergence rate
but before I do that this is a program
on bridging continuous and discrete
optimization so I thought it'd be worth
talking a bit about I think one of my
favorite combinatorial problems the
maximum flow problem and how these
results relate to getting faster
algorithms for combinatorial problems
like the maximum flow problem in
particular I want to discuss this
problems I think it serves as a nice
problem on the boundary of continuous
and discrete optimization that
highlights I think the difficulties and
butch approaches to get faster running
times all right so for the next little
bit the system is a quick aside think
about solving the maximum flow problem
so here we have a directed graph G with
vertices V and edges E we have some
non-negative capacity on the edges you
we have two special vertices s and T and
our goal now is to send as much stuff as
possible from s to T without exceeding
the capacity constraints right some of
the most well studied problems in
combinatorial optimization and until the
last few years the fastest algorithms we
had for solving this result solving this
problem where the sum of the similar
result of Goldberg and Rho that showed
that you can compute the maximum flow in
a running time that's the smaller of the
number of edges of the graph raised to
the three house and the number of edges
times the number of vertices in the
graph raised to the 2/3 okay all right
so how does this compare it to all the
linear programming and to your point
machinery we've been talking about well
it's not too hard to write the maximum
flow problem as a linear program we
simply add an edge from T to s we say we
want to look at the set of flows such
that the flow on into every vertex is
the same as the flow out of every vertex
that's just a bunch of linear
constraints now how ever much flow we
put on TS is about same as amount of
flow that'll go from s to T so we just
want to make a cost so that we put as
much flow on our TS edge as possible and
we just want to make sure that we meet
the capacity constraints so if you just
try to solve this and if you just take
the standard
the standard linear programming
formulation maximum flow and try to
apply renderers result or use the log
barrier to solve or any of the methods
we've seen to solve this linear program
you immediately get an algorithm that
solves this linear program in square
root of the number sorry n squared of
the number of edges iterations so now if
you want to look at the actual
complexity of these results you can look
at the actual linear systems you'd have
to solve in every iteration the actual
Newton steps you'd have to implement and
it turns out here if you're trying to
solve this linear system in this matrix
matrix transpose you can show this
matrix is symmetric diagonally dominant
and using this beautiful powerful very
influential work of spilling tang of
2004 you can show that you can solve
every one of those systems in nearly
linear time and the number of edges in
the graph so if you just put these two
things together which Dyson Spielman did
in 2008 along the way of achieving some
other cool results you get an algorithm
for solving maximum flow that
essentially matches the best running
time we had for combinatorial results at
least in the regime of sparse graphs so
sometimes they show that the maximum
flow problem is a natural barrier for
sort of the limits of combinatorial
techniques and limits of continuous
techniques which ever you apply it seems
like this number of edges to the three
halves at least in the case of sparse
graphs shows up so now you know you can
imagine where I'm going with this I
talked about how you can get faster
interior point methods that depend
better on the dimension of the problem
you would think well there's only V
vertices this seems like the intrinsic
dimension of the problem so imagine the
first thing I try to do we try to do is
use that result to get a better running
time for maximum flow to have only
squared number vertices iterations
rather than square number of edges
unfortunately things are not quite that
simple doesn't work right away if you
look at this linear programming
formulation we have any quality
constraints here number of vertices and
equality constraints but we have this
number of edges two-sided inequality
constraints so this problem is number of
edges dimensional and if you take the
dual and any's try to take the dual of
it
right in any sort of standard form you
still end up from the two-sided and
equality constraints getting something
that has number of edges number of
variables so it's not clear how
immediately in this formulation you can
use the same off-the-shelf machinery to
get a square root of vertices iteration
count however it turns out you can use
the same machinery nevertheless to build
an interior point method for this
constraint set that still converges at a
rate that depends just on the number of
equality constraints which were max-flow
corresponds to a number of vertices and
this gives you and putting those
together if you do get an algorithm for
solving the maximum flow problem that
gets a number of edges times square root
of number of vertices in terms of
runtime yeah in practice we really would
expect that you're just getting about Yi
mean I mean in practice it would be much
faster essentially things that we know
in worst case take quadratic time in
practice they work in the quadratic one
of the less glorious you know is use
case of asymptotic theory of course but
if the picture changes the moment you
move to the mean cost max flow then the
existing daggers are not like the
computer vision of this good and
actually then you might want be tempted
to use can people use networks right
perforce better but oh yeah
at least there is there is a clearly
likely need for
like the opportunity so we ended up just
building a barrier for this two-sided
constraint set and arguing that you can
still do path following on this set that
converges at square root number of
equality constraints rate so we end up
just showing you can do path following
on it directly even though there's not a
universal barrier for it yep
and I'm on the record so I've I've heard
I can tell you what I talked more about
I'll find I've heard of a number of
attempts to use the interior point
methods to solve max flow and I guess
there there's also the question of using
the linear system solving machinery
faster well they do in practice I mean
people have been optimizing it more
recently in light of these results all I
can say is that I got one of the very
smart graduate students very and happy
with me when I asked him to implement my
algorithm well as I say in theory I
still think it's incredibly exciting
time to be in studying interior point
methods there's been a number of recent
results showing and giving evidence that
in some cases we can possibly go beyond
standard self concordance theory
alexander talked about some results
yesterday he has on modifying and to
your point perturbing the central path
and modifying into your point methods to
get a faster algorithm for maximum flow
and unit capacity graphs or it's even
faster if the graphs just have mildly
bounded capacities at this point it's
also been used different ways of
modifying interior point methods to the
structure problem and use to get faster
atoms for shortest paths with negative
edge weights and there's been recent
work showing that you can use it to
solve even some continuous optimization
problems like geometric median and your
linear time so I think with all these
results together it means it's exciting
times possibly studying into your point
methods and better tailoring these
methods to the structure of problems to
get faster algorithms alright so that's
all I'm gonna say about maximum flow in
the running time of linear programming
what I want to do in the rest of the
talk is talk a little bit more about the
geometric perspective we use to
this faster running time for linear
programming and speculate about some
open problems any questions on this
before I go on
alright alright so to build this result
let's take a ticket from where we were
at the end of Alexander's talk the other
day we'll take as a starting point a
basic path following approach for
interior point methods we talked about
and talked about how to modify the use
of the logarithmic barrier to get faster
algorithms so what we saw yesterday is
the way these path following methods
work path on interior point methods work
so we want to minimize solve this linear
program we assume we'll have some nice
barrier function P defined on the
interior of the polytope such that the
value of the function goes to infinity
as we approach the boundary of the
polytope and the way will optimize then
over the polytope is well consider
parameterizing how much we care about
minimizing the barrier function versus
how much we care about minimizing the
cost so what we'll do is consider some
penalized objective function
parameterize by a path parameter T where
T will denote how much we care about
minimizing the cost versus how much we
care about minimizing the barrier and
what we'll do is consider the
minimizer's of this penalized objective
function for varying values of T so if
we take T to be zero we're only
minimizing the barrier function over the
polytope which corresponds to getting
some sort of center of the polytope
induced by the barrier and if we tend
take the limit of increasing T we're
minimizing more and more the objective
function while staying just enough to
away from the boundary of function for
the fact that it's going to infinity not
to kill us so in the limit this will go
to the optimum the minimizer of the
linear program and as we saw from the
talk the way the these path following
methods work so we typically do some
initial transformation to get some point
that's close to some central path point
for some value of T what we do is we
increase the path parameter by some
multiplicative constant and then we do
some Newton steps to compute the next
central path point and we repeat so
we've started some central path point
increase T use Newton to get the next
central path point and continue till
we're at the optimum of the polytope
alright and to recap the analysis of
this method boiled down to essentially
two facts
the first fact is that we assumed that
our penalty function P with self
concordant what this means is that we've
made an assumption that the Hessian how
much it changes is bounded if we move
our point by a bounded amount in the
Hessian norm so we can bound changes in
the Hessian by movements of points in
Hessian norm the way you usually think
about this it says is if you take some
point for this barrier function you do a
change of basis to make the Hessian the
identity then what it says is if you
move in a ball around that point the
Hessian stays looking like the identity
which then from all the talks we've seen
earlier this week about first-order
methods for optimization that means if
the norm of the gradient and this change
of basis is small meaning a step of
gradient descent will move you to much
the Hessian still won't change too much
and locally everything will be well
conditioning we're in vertically so
thinking about that one that means with
undoing the change of basis then tells
you that if the norm of the gradient is
small and the Hessian inverse norm
meaning the size of the Newton step is
small and the Hessian norm then if you
take a few steps of Newton's method
you'll rapidly converge to the central
path point every step will may it will
have your error or more the second
property we use to then analyze these
paths following methods is that we
assumed in some sense the total force
exerted by the barrier was not too large
so here we're making an assumption self
concordance is assuming that the barrier
doesn't change too quickly and the
second assumption so it's fairly stable
like it's pretty principled where you
stay the second function we're saying is
somehow though how much it pushes you
isn't too hard so when you look at going
from one central path point to the next
things don't change too much there
should be a gradient sign there yeah
this you know is scary-looking
expression and over there is exactly the
mutant decrement from my talk yes yeah I
stole it from your talk yes that's why I
picked one time yes
so I forgive me for not saying it that's
exactly why I did it yes to do all
so totally agree this is yes this is the
same as the new agreed yep right and the
the analysis under essentially showed
was that if you have the property that
the norm of the gradient and the Hessian
of the barrier in the Hester universe
norm is less than nu then this says if
we increase the path parameter T by
mount that depends on new right then we
can maintain that the Newton decrement
is too small this this is exactly what I
was going to just talk to say that you
can increase T by a multiplicative 1
plus 1 over square root nu and still
stay in the region where the Newton
decrement is small so just having these
two properties is enough that you get a
square root new iteration algorithm okay
and this is just recapping the analysis
Alexander did all right so what I want
to do now is say so what's the picture
behind this was this essentially say so
if we it says that if we're trying to
minimize a linear program we have this
piece off concordant barrier function
says that if we look at one central path
point T and we look at the level sets of
that barrier function around X T which
is essentially it looks it's pretty well
behaved quadratic it just looks like a
quadratic based only on the Hessian all
right and then what the analysis we
essentially what those two properties
imply is that if you increase T by a
multiplicative 1 plus 1 over square root
mu then if you look at the next central
path point the Hessian hasn't changed
too much
so the Hessians are still comparable
they're only off by some constant and
that second point was still in the
region where there was a good
approximation to the Hessian for the
last point so it says whenever you make
multiplicative approximations the path
parameter but you can actually show it's
multiplicative 1 plus or minus 1 over
square of you essentially the Hessian
doesn't change too much and you stay in
the region where Newton would converge
quickly so you can move forward and
backward along the central path so the
way I usually think of this is that
these two results together are saying
that if we took this original
ill-conditioned problem of minimizing a
linear program
by having this ability property of the
Hessian self concordance and this
property about how much the bear how
much force the barrier exerts we're
essentially saying we can everywhere
carve up the Hesse carve up the feasible
region into a bunch of overlapping
ellipses where we have bounds on the
rates that they change so we can move
out between these regions between them
yeah so a better a lower barrier
parameter would they look more like the
poly tope or like less like I mean you
know as the as as the barrier parameter
somehow it gets better I guess it's a I
guess the barrier gets better the range
in which the ellipse is a good
approximation to everything gets larger
so let me do the next thing I was going
to do I'll make it cleaner so there's
another geometric property implied by
the barrier functions I find a little
cleaner that I usually think about so
another way to think about what's going
on is if you take a self concordant
function a nice property that they have
is that if what you do is you compute
look at the center of the polytope so
what you do is you consider the point
where you're only minimizing the barrier
function and if what I do is plot the
second-order Taylor approximation to the
function or in other words I just look
at the points where the amount so if I
look at the second door that should be a
squared sorry so if I look at the second
order Taylor approximation so look at
the deacon ellipse this is the set of
all points such that the distance from
the point in the Hessian norm is at most
one this gives you some ellipse that
sits inside the polytope and you can
prove that always happens and if you
have a new self concordant barrier you
can show that if you take that same
ellipse and you scale it up by a factor
of Oh a V so you consider all the points
such that the distance they are from
your center is at most
nu nu in the Hessian norm you can show
that that ellipse fully contains the
polytope
so another way I think of thinking of
self concordance this is technically a
property implied by self concordance is
when you have a self concordant Barrett
says the center always gives you an
ellipse that up to a factor of nu well
approximates the entire poly tope yeah
so the way I prove this is technically
it's a great question the way I say this
is technically for the center of the
polytope when you minimize only the
barrier function when you're following
the central path and now you've
minimized some amount of cost plus
barrier the story's a little more
complicated but you should essentially
still think you're locally getting a new
like rounding to the polytope wherever
you are you have to carefully
incorporate the fact of the cost
function MASINT any questions
so another way to think of these
properties that were using in the path
following analysis is that where we're
requiring is that the Hesse doesn't
change too much self concordance and
we're requiring that the Hessian always
induces this good rounding of the
polytope that it's a good sort of
geometric approximation to the polytope
around where you are so so taking this
perspective if we look at render guards
algorithm where the law gets be a little
more specific if we look at the
logarithmic barrier for solving the
linear program so this was the barrier
where we simply take a point we look at
the distance to every constraint and we
take one over the distance that
constraint take the log of that and
summed it up for every constraint if we
compute the center for the logarithmic
barrier function this is a special name
it's called the analytic center of the
polytope again you can show the log
barriers and end rounding of the
polytope so if I take the second order
approximation of if I take the second
order approximation around the center
and scale up by a factor of n I get
ellipse that fully contains the poly
tope all right and you should think that
this end is roughly the N in the number
of it are in those that's we take the
square root of in the number of
iterations in an interior point method
all right but now even if I lost you
somewhere in that intuition it's not too
hard to see that there's something in
this algorithm that should depend
something about the rate that should
depend more on the particular
representation of the polytope the
number of constraints n rather than the
dimension of the polytope and to see
that as a quick illustrative example
suppose we took our instance of our
linear program we took a few constraints
and we just repeated them many many
times ok so we just we didn't change the
linear program we had to solve I just
keep adding a bunch of redundant rows
and our constraint matrix a this doesn't
change what we're optimizing over but a
quick look at the logarithmic barrier
functions it does change the barrier
we're working with we just repeat a
constraint a number of times essentially
what we're doing is increasing the
weight on a certain number of
constraints so the way to think of this
is you can think in the choice of how
the particular poly tope or optimism
over was represented the adversary and
how they give us this representation can
use what weighted log barrier were
aiming for and the amount of control one
way you can measure them out of the
control they have here is the number of
constraints n right so from that it's
not so hard to see that if I do this
it'll actually shift over the central
path that'll push things away from this
constraint set and couldn't make the
convergence of the algorithm slower I
think this also suggests a very natural
thing to do if you want to improve the
rate of interior point methods and
Alexander talked about this briefly the
other day you know if the issue is the
adversary can the choice of giving us
the representation the polytope can
force us to work with some weighted log
barrier then a natural thing we should
do is optimize over those weights we
should take that control back and that's
the rough idea we'll explore for how to
actually modify the logarithmic barrier
to get a rate that better depends on the
dimension of the polytope all right so
that all sounds well and good in
principle however it doesn't Issei
immediately why you should suspect that
doing any sort of manipulation of the
waste should give you something it
depends on squared dimension rather than
square root of number of constraints
it's kind of weird and it does happen as
you really want the central path to like
those constraints shouldn't matter at
all right yeah agreed
done mother for dancer but they might
not afford algorithm I think it's I
guess like big simplex does it look at
those constraints yes agreed agreed and
in some sense I guess the the log
barrier does decay things that they
matter less and less as you get closer
closer there I guess the issue is when
you start in the middle you can repeat
when you're in the middle here you may
not really know what's going on and by
repeating them so much it forces you to
run into one of the walls and you can
slow down examples of like worst case
example
barriers they really like brute force by
just getting that really really large
weights it is like they really like put
some exponential size in like weights
although these things to be really wild
well if there's a way to weight the
constraints appropriately repeat things
are done early enough that you can walk
all along a Clemente humans you can
imagine cases that's not even quite this
like here this case it's kind of obvious
you downplay it I guess the worry is if
there's a bunch of redundant like maybe
there's a constraint here that's
repeated many many times right that
would keep you going away from opt and
when you want to do you really want to
decay in the beginning to already kind
of a weird property of interior point
methods that other methods don't
necessarily have right no I'll take this
more apply it I would say I'm saying it
easier when you've convinced me I
definitely should have had the redundant
constraint at the bottom that would me
to look worse yeah okay anyway alright
right so we're saying repeating
constraints can change where the central
path actually goes we want to undo is
undo this effect but why should we hope
there's a reading that lets us actually
run at a rate depends on the dimension
the polytope well a quick way to see
that is if what we're aiming for is a
good rounding of the polytope there's a
natural beautiful result in convex
geometry we can look to where it's known
that if you take any poly tope or any
convex body and you look at the maximum
volume ellipse contained inside that
convex body then that's always in
dimension rounding of the polytope so it
always gives you an ellipse that you
could skip that contain the poly tope
that you could scale up by a factor of D
to contain it so that says at least
there's some ellipsoid to look for in
order to hope to get it better rounding
and the reason it gives hope for
possibly trying to optimize over the
weights is that you can show that the
John ellipse of a polytope this d
rounding is actually always realizable
as the deccan ellipse of a sir
weighted log barrier in other words
there's always way to reweighed the log
barrier so that if you compute that the
center under those weights and look at
its Hessian it gives you a D rounding of
the polytope I think this also gives a
natural barrier that you would look for
if you wanted to try to get a better
convergence rate you could try computing
the John ellipse this maximum volume
ellipse and doing something like maybe
taking some function of the volume we're
trying to take something where the
Hessian looks like the John ellipse so
just try to do a convergence right now
so I guess in general you would yeah so
right so here I guess we're trying to
give a space to hope for better
convergence rate the John ellipse if you
want to compute it precisely you can sum
it you can write down another interior
point it has let me definite procam it's
obvious there's a little some chicken
the egg problem there but yeah good
question
yeah
yeah that's a really good point
distributes is saying like even if you
started with the symmetric convex body
and initially you had an ellipse that is
squared D approximation as you start to
go towards any of the vertices locally
things don't look as symmetric had to
debate with people about whether or not
that fact that you just said is part of
where the square root comes from but
maybe take such speculation offline I'm
not sure I'm not sure happy to chat
about that after there's a really good
question though the question was are we
showing that for the flow polytope you
get better rounding yeah I don't want to
I would take me a little too long to
think about that right now
yeah let's take this discussion offline
I want to go a bit more into the next
steps alright so again so this does say
there's some D rounding the polytope to
look for we could try to compute the
John ellipse and take maximal natural
functions of its volume or something
like that to get a barrier
unfortunately there's some immediate
issues that come up when you try to do
that first of all if you try to solve
the maximization problem over weights to
get the John ellipse you can show that
the weights that you would optimize over
not unique so working in the space of
weights over the log barrier is not a
very nice ones if you have two redundant
constraints whether you put more weight
in one or the other doesn't really
affect the deccan ellipse at all and
even if you could deal with the sort of
degenerate seasoning in the weights if
you tried to do any sort of central path
where the Hessian was the John ellipse
and some weighted sense that doesn't
necessarily induce a smooth path like
the Hessian can sort of have kinks and
how it changes which would make
following it very difficult alright so
now that I guess were through the end of
bootcamp
but what do you do if you still have
this natural sort of geometric object
that seems to have all the right sort of
geometric properties but it's low for
the sake of iterative methods because
it's not
they're not strongly convex or changes a
little more than should what do you do
you regularize exactly so that's a
natural thing you could do you could add
in some small penalty terms to make sure
that the weights you get are canonical
and that you could try to make it so
that the Hessian doesn't change too
quickly you can also add some stuff to
make the weights not get too small
basically could add a bunch of simple
functions to get the weights that you're
optimizing over to be much better
behaved and then hopefully also have the
deccan ellipse that you're working with
more stable it turns out there's a way
to do this and it gives you a D rounding
and the short answer is that formula
will do it so you can solve this
following regularize John ellipse
computation problem this as a barrier
function will give you something that
gives an almost D rounding of the
polytope so something that's a d
rounding up to poly log n so I don't
wouldn't really I can talk to you about
this formula more offline weird and try
to break it down the main point too much
the main point is these first two terms
you can think of being used to consider
it to make it so that the jaw know that
the deccan ellipse is a good rounding
and then this term is also added to make
sure that the weights are spread out
fairly uniformly so that the ellipse you
have is somewhat stable and this term is
also added to simplify the analysis and
make sure that none of the weights get
too small and if you work with this
rounding you can show it gives you an
end rounding of the polytope and this
actually gives you a barrier you can
essentially follow with a path following
method that gives you square root these
should each be DS that's a bad punchline
it gives you a D rounding of the
polytope and a squared d iteration
algorithm all right and you can show
that this this actually works all right
but for but note the proof of this is
quite is a bit complicated an easier way
to do it rather than directly trying to
show this as self concordant turns out
is much easier to show that there's a
Hessian that everywhere well
approximates the Hessian of this
function and that Hessian is very stable
and that turns out to be sufficient for
path following methods okay but if
you've ever tried to look at this result
you might be asking now why is the proof
so long these results are
getting up there and length this is a
little bit of a complicated formula but
it's not that complicated and
essentially with all our path following
analysis we've reduced analyzing an
interior point method using this barrier
just two bounding the first few
derivatives of it and like clearly it
can't take that much calculus to bound
the first three derivatives of this
barrier essentially the main issue that
comes up if you try to work with this
barrier function is exactly the one that
you eluded to trying to actually compute
the John ellipse is a bit expensive and
even more damning pretty much anything
you would try to do with the barrier of
this function will involve computing the
gradient of log debt which will involve
computing the diagonal of a projection
matrix which would give us exactly the
same sort of slowdown we were trying to
avoid and moving to using vytas methods
all right so what exactly is this issue
and why should we hope to do better so
again the gradient computation what
shows up if you do any analysis is in
the gradient of log that you need to
compute what are known as leverage
scores or in the graph case or known as
effective resistances and they're
essentially the diagonal of this
projection matrix a matrix by so this
projection matrix we're using that's
there is a corresponds to the linear
system we want to solve you need to
compute its diagonal and if we're gonna
do this naively you'd have to either use
phage pass matrix multiplication or
solve and linear systems to get every
one of the diagonal entries that's the
bottleneck fortunately there's a very
yeah
so your weights are show me the screen
so I guess I want them not negative but
we have a barrier for it we want them
not negative but there's a barrier for
it so but you mentioned it that the last
term so here we have this minus sum sum
of WI so essentially I'll get that the
total weight solely there will be of d
log D like good question yes
entropy trim just make it is that what
makes it so that I guess the weights
don't change by more than a factor do or
something yeah so the entropy term is
what's adding canonical miss to the
weight so it says if we have a bunch the
same rich constraint repeated many times
there's a canonical way to assign the
weights between them which then also
makes it easy to talk about so it gives
strong convexity to the optimization
problem over W which then corresponds to
stability in the Hessian it's not enough
so that's enough the last term is enough
that stops the weights from getting too
small but it doesn't stop them from only
changing by a small amount it doesn't
really give you anything like self
concordance I don't think now that I
have a formal proof that it doesn't but
right so this the last sorry the last
it's a good question so the last term we
use to make sure that none of them are
smaller than roughly D over N and this
will ensure that none of them are much
larger than a constant probably like to
this barrier won't work this so so no so
this won't work because you can't
compute gradients of it really this
would be a good beer so this barrier
gives you a square root D iteration
algorithm it doesn't give you an
iteration cost of solving a Polliwog
number of linear systems so it doesn't
give you faster max flow
sadly yeah yeah last one then I'm gonna
have to if you did use this you would
have to compute you have to solve it
opposition problem at every step to
compute the very good good good good
question but you can all right what will
you show is you can show that the
weights don't change too much so you can
use the fact that you computed the
barrier recently to compute the next
barrier and this is essentially the
types of issues that we'll have to get
through to get that's a good that issue
will also show up when we try to get
this to run fast great question
all right so again we said the issue
here was trying to the issue here but
the first issue is you can't even
compute gradients of the barrier quickly
even if you knew the optimal weights so
even if you knew the optimal weights you
wouldn't be able to recenter with in
terms of X you couldn't implement the
Newton steps
fortunately there's a clever trick that
seems like it would help which is that
this matrix here is a projection matrix
so it turns so if we wanted to compute
any diagonal entry of this matrix that's
the same as computing the l2 norm
squared of a column of the matrix
because the matrix times itself is
itself and since then the MIT with the
quantities we're interested in are
simply the l 2-norm Squared's of every
single column of this matrix you can use
this clever trick that Spielman serve
also used in 2008 which essentially that
you can apply johnson lyndon stress to
this you can take you can essentially
project the projection matrix down to
login dimensions and that'll give you a
multiplicative approximation to the l2
norm of every single column so if you do
this if you just compute this a
projection matrix and then multiply from
the left this just gives you essentially
the l2 norm of every column up to a
multiplicative constant all right so
this says hopeful it says we only need
to solve a poly log number of linear
systems which were in our budget to do
and we can estimate multiplicatively
every coordinate of this term that shows
up in the gradient right unfortunately
if any of you been working with interior
point methods a lot this should raise a
really red flag the idea of using
multiplicative approximations to things
in the gradient what's that red
anybody okay so the big problem is that
things the gradients yeah so so if you
try to run Newton's method or implement
these path following methods you can
tolerate a lot of error in the Hessian
you only need to get the Hessian
multiplicatively approximately however
in order to actually Center to go to the
central path you do need a very precise
estimate to the gradient so just having
constant multiplicative error in every
corner the gradient will let you even
certify that you're close stopped all
right so it's just much more arid that
you can tolerate so the way to get
around this so unfortunately we can't
quite use this barrier because even
checking that you're near a central path
point is sort of more expensive in the
amount of time we want to spend so to
get around this we do is actually go use
this app has a path finding instead of
actually manipulating the weights of a
weighted log barrier so again we said
this idea was if we had the logarithmic
barrier the problem was that we one of
the problems was that by giving a bunch
of redundant constraints you can change
the central path and you can think that
if your barrier you were using was the
weighted log barrier then every single
set of weights induces a different
central path you could take through the
polytope so another way of thinking what
we were saying before is that by
rewedding constraints you can force the
central path to go somewhere else and if
our idea is to optimize over double you
can think this is picking a better
essential path or finding a better
essential path to follow everything you
said just just is about the constraints
yep but the central path to get a
penalty
choo-choo-choo-choo so so another way
say but I guess we can think of that as
parameterised through X but yes right so
we were saying we want weights to have
this rounding property local to where it
is inside the polytope but the other
issue I'm saying that'll help deal with
right now is that you can think though
if you ever following a particular
weighted central path you have a certain
set of weights this is something that
you can actually Center on very quickly
computing the gradient and the Hessian
of the weighted log barrier is no harder
than computing the gradient and the
Hessian of the standard log barrier so
what that means is if instead we were
using some weighted log barrier and the
weights happen to have the right
properties that are surrounding we'd be
in good shape because we could actually
compute the gradients of that fast and
compute the Hessian of that quickly so
the idea is rather than using solving
this joint optimization problem where
the barrier comes from maximization over
the weights instead what we'll view is
just use the weights that that barrier
would have given us is advice over which
central path to follow the idea is as
follows what we'll do is maintain both X
and a set of weights we'll maintain that
X is on the central path for the current
path parameter and the current coin of
weights so we give some initial point
for which that happens and then what
we'll do is we'll take a Newton step on
X and W to move X to B as the center of
the weighted log barrier for our current
set of weights and then what we'll do is
computes on the side some ideal weight
function that would give us the same
sort of local optimality the local
properties we would have from our
idealized barrier and use that as sort
of the ideal weights we wish we had at
the current point and move our weights
towards those ideal weights and we'll
repeat the idea here is what way to
weight functions should we use well
before we're saying we would essentially
solve the fot this problem and minimize
over X and then our barrier would be
maximizing over wise double use of the
volume and along with this regularizer
and the ideas will still just use the
maximization problem that we were
solving here for W as I'd like the ideal
weights we wish we had
all right and we'll move towards that
and here we have the nice property that
even if we only have these weights
approximately we can still Center
efficiently all right so hopefully we
can tolerate the air so what do you need
any special properties of the weights to
guarantee the Newton steps do get you
closer to central fat because yeah so
I'll talk about that in a sec I'll talk
about said I'm running short on time so
I might speed up difference the N now
huh sorry yeah all right so anyway this
is this scheme that we actually use and
we can show that it works that if you do
this where you're centering on X and W
and then updating weights from sort of
the same maximization problem that would
have induced that John ellipse this
converges always gives you the right
local properties that you can move along
the central path far and that the
central path doesn't change too much and
the idea here is that we're saying we'll
alternate between moving down the
central path and Optum and changing the
weights to find a better central path
nearby for us to follow and the idea
that is instead of actually optimizing
this like idealized optimal barrier
we're always optimizing some sort of
nearby barrier that well approximates it
now when you hear this at first it
sounds like a free lunch it seems like I
said you can't tolerate multiplicative
error and then I just said you could
tolerate it anyway what's difficult
about this is the proof that this works
is much harder we're now decoupling
these two optimization problems the X
optimization problem from the W
optimization problem so we no longer can
argue about this one idealized convex
function we're working with instead it's
these two sort of disjoint optimization
problems we have to prove or a couple
together well enough that everything
works out and the other issue you have
to do to do this is that again we can't
actually compute the weight so we can
only compute it approximately so we need
we can take on only compute
approximately so we have to do work to
make sure we can always track the
optimal weights this takes some work but
you can prove there's a scheme that lets
you stay close to the optimal weight by
the fact that we know the true weights
don't move too much and we always get a
multiplicative aprox
so that's all I wanted to say about that
I have a lot of open somewhat fun open
problems but I am far out of time
science I can show this slides all right
one of these days I'll get to have more
than two minutes at the end of a talk to
talk about the open problems anyway so
the Oh may I'll just keep it at the joke
side I'll keep it as so the open
problems are solved max flow faster
solve linear programs faster I'm like a
soft convex problem I have this set up
any questions to do another time okay so
yeah so maybe I like the idea for the
connection the question is is there
predictor-corrector interpretation of
the weights two things a great question
I guess the one thing is note there's
not much we're not really doing anything
optimistic like it is a short step
interior point method like we are moving
by a fixed amount every single time
there's none of the the really
prediction part where we try to reach
far down the central path let's say deal
with
all right I guess we're doing it to deal
with the fact that we can't compute the
true weight so we can compute the true
weights we just do it and be done and I
guess it's optimistic that we're hoping
that you can stay near by the wits but
but there's a fixed bound on saying a in
the sense that we're guessing I totally
agree
I wish virus is part of like we are
trying to do something optimistic and
reach further down the path and that's
not currently there in the analysis but
I think doing something like that could
be quite interesting right so what we do
is we make sure that the weights an
average wean every iteration are always
sort of close to each other
multiplicatively
so the weight problem is always locally
well conditioned and then we say with
the approximate linear system solves
that's enough that you stay
multiplicatively close to the true
weights so there's a few procedure to
these two procedures wrapped in there
one sort of projected gradient to try to
compute the right weights and then
another opposition for our guess of the
weights to stay close to that guess and
that's that's how that works
I mean you take the deep tightness
constraints and so I think there's a
great question can you properly sparsa
Phi in any of this because right now
we're sort of downplaying the impact of
all but the they all make a contribution
to the gradient like we don't have
proper one of the open problems that
have been in the can you properly get
sub linear iterates for the sake of
input sparsity or for solving them even
faster it's a great open problem that we
don't know how to do right now D wins
over what I've told you at least
emphasize this need this question would
be can you solve a number of others
perfect imagine using diplomatic is like
we know it's solvable in n no matter
would need to keep that variable like
they we know we know that the smallest
in size small number I can do it in two
minutes no I I'm all for this challenge
I'll take that bad bad just clicked it
238 yeah I'm not listening to you open
problems alright first can you improve
interior point methods on its own game
this question of how many Newton steps
do you need how many gradients and
Hessian inverse evaluations of the log
barrier open how many do you need
upper bound evidence there's all this
cool permutation lower bound evidence
there's lower bounds on
predictor-corrector hope or you can do
permutation all sorts of cool
acceleration stuff including accelerated
cubic regularization other idea we can
do much more than project onto polytopes
we have nonlinear operators for
projecting onto certain convex sets we
understand well enough particular
maximum flow we can project in L
infinity versus the l2 that linear
assist that the l2 that linear peer
point method standardly use can we use
any of the structured results to get a
better interior point method how do you
actually use that other idea we already
talked about can you use something of
get your iteration cost even cheaper
there's all this cool work on being able
to solve their inner algorithms very
very quickly by sampling can use any of
the sampling stochastic machinery to
maybe solve linear programs input
sparsity time linear when there's enough
constraints the other idea this thing
that we know the number of constraints
don't then there's a bound on how many
you know that on average changes the
Hessian or low rank
seems very suggestive of on average
slacks are changing on average long
steps over the central path they're well
conditioned there's all sorts of things
like coordinate descent and strg to
exploit that can we use it
we kind of did in geometric median which
was fun and I can tell you about later
and I think that was a minute I have
heading 0.5 feet that will be help
finish by saying you know thanks so much
to Nick Hill bendin Pablo for organizing
the boot camp thanks to all the speakers
and there will be an All Hands meeting
at 3:00 p.m. what to do is such a lovely
like began the semester thanks
[Applause]